hello everyone and welcome back to the
Magnusson rotational we are at the final
game between Dengler and Fabiano Caruana
basically game 5 this is d Armageddon
ding gets 5 minutes whereas Fabi gets 4
minutes on the clock but the dink has to
win in order to win the match and the
Fabi only needs a draw
that's how Armageddon works and yeah as
I understand this fob you won the coin
toss or whatever they're using to you
know to give whoever wins the tone calls
the opportunity to choose where he will
be black-on-white Fabi won and then he
chose that he he prefers to be black so
ding is the one that that's forced to
win here so that being said let's see
how ding went about this
so ding opens with the ready Knight to
f3 we have d5 and g3 so what we've
already seen g6 Bishop g2 Bishop to g7
and d4 now we have Knight to f6 by Fabi
and castles now c6 strengthening and e5
+ b3 now now preparing to develop this
Bishop I also think at doing it
we have castles and now just c4 and also
this is a very nice calm approach you're
gonna be in Cairo both of your bishops
slowly but steadily develop your pieces
instead of just rushing into some crazy
positions like a maniac because you need
to win the game so a 5 by Fabi yeah
Bishop Delphi was the most common move
here a5 is somewhat rarer but Fabi also
makes very nice use of it with a 5 and
Knight to c3 now now we have Knight to
e4 Bobby has a clear idea of of this a5
so he goes for Knight to e4 he wants to
capture the knight on c3 and then bust
open the Queen side with a 4 so Bishop
to b2 and now Knight captures on c3
Bishop captures and now a4 so makes
sense we have C captures by doing seek
actress and now just be captures on a4
and here ding wins the pawn however his
pawns are double here and Fabio
obviously knows these positions since he
since he goes into it so Bishop to d7
goes after the e4 pawn and now Queen b3
that okay you capped Ronnie for I'm
gonna pick up the Beast seven point and
there is one game in the database where
each sex was played but here five just
grabs the pawn and it is as of more 13
that we have a completely new game so
thing goes for the b7 pawn and threatens
to win the rook and now Knight to c6 now
everything is nicely defended so rook F
the b1 putting more pressure on the B
file we have Queen to b6 now preparing
to bring the other rook into the game I
hope for we trap the Queen
so Queen back to b2 and now Knight to a5
and this Knight is now coming to c4 we
have Bishop to b4 now challenging the
Queen and the Queen back to e6 keeping
an eye on the east 7th pawn while also
pressuring the e2 bonding plays III and
now Knights the c4 with an attack on the
Queen Queen to a2 and Bishop to b5 and
if you look at this position before
Bishop to b5 it's a it's a very nice
position for both players but ding is
the one who has the extra pawn and it's
a past a pawn so it's not you know just
any any pawn but Bobby goes to Bishop to
b5 here he threatens a lot of nasty
discoveries here and here he allows
doing a certain tactic it's not the the
most clever of tactics it's Bishop
characters on e7 just winning up another
pawn while opening up an attack towards
his Bishop here and you don't really
have a good reply to this if you capture
just real characters here and you start
pushing your pawn here however however
unlikely dink misses this tactic like I
said it might be because it's very late
where he's at over it's past 1 a.m. and
it also could be that you're just not
expecting far better to blunder
basically the game like that so instead
he goes Queen to a1 and now comes look F
to B it quickly defending that Bishop so
nice the d2 offers more trades and now
Queen to d7 makes room for the e5 pawn
we have Knight to b3 now with maybe
ideas of shifting of the night over to
c5 but II 5 immediately we have D
captures Knight captures and now comes
Bishop the c3 just challenging 5 is
Bishop on g7
we have Bishop to c4 now Bobby will she
all of his attention unto that 8u pawn
you want to play something like rookie
six double hooks and the a file and go
after well that pawn so Queen to d2 the
Queen will also help out with the
defense and Queen to f5 now with idea so
maybe delivering a check here forcing
white to give up the LightSquared bishop
so rook the d1 also adding wants to keep
an eye on the d3 square and now h5
preparing h4 to bust open dings king
size King side we have nice to d4
attacking the Queen and Queen back to d7
and now h4 Dean doesn't allow Fabi to
push h4 and rook to a3 now this is how
Bobby decides to double up rocks and the
a file will rug beat the c1 adding more
protection to the bishop here and now
just a rugby ta it now threatening to
just straight-up win this pawn and here
being defense woodwork the c2 and there
really isn't a nicer way to defend you
have to play something you could go for
Knight to f3 offer this trade on e5 but
the Indians black always captures on a -
so dink tries rook to c2 this defense
the pawn however it gives Fabi this
maneuver Bishop to d3 where it's
impossible to go rook here because of
night the c-4 winning material so dinky
is forced to go back to C 1 and fo b
just repeats Bishop to c4 because Fabi
is now happy with a drop it's Armageddon
so Dean has to figure out something else
he goes Knight the b3 instead now puts
pressure on the d5 pawn and Queen to f5
again going for that f3 square while
also keeping around d3 square with all
of these pieces so ding repeats rook to
d1 but now Fabi finds the exquisite
Knight to f3 check with Bishop captures
and now a nice tuition to Bishop
characters and c3 Queen captures on c3
and now Queen captures on f3 and Fabi
was has successfully traded off pretty
much everything and now it's a pretty
equal ish position everything goes Queen
to a-1 everything is nicely defended
that you will have to give up ba to pawn
but you know we've established that a
long time ago it's a 94 and the game
continues
however being here played Queen to be 2
he decided to keep an
and the pawn and not you know not
interested in giving it up
however this blunder is the game for
dink and dust the match so feel free to
pause the video here and try to find the
move that wins the game for Fabi while
I'll give you a couple of seconds so for
those of you who noticed that the Queen
is also attacking the rook on d1
congratulations on spotting it not that
you need to capture it right away but
for those of you who just want to enjoy
the show
it's rook capture Sunday - this is what
Fabi played and it was in this position
unmoved 36 that tinglin resigned the
game and with it the match so very
interesting you know turn of events
first ding winning Game three Fabia
needing to win on demand then Fabi wins
even though ding had a winning position
he could trap that rook a quarantined
rook and also here a couple of very nice
chances missed by ding and of course
that's a hole Fabi needs to win the
match so of course here you resigned
because there there is no move if you
capture the rook then first black will
capture this one with cheque you move
the king and then just rook captures
here Queen captures and you just pick up
the knight and that's it or even or even
there's a forced mate after Bishop to f1
check which is just a very nice maneuver
Bishop to f1 check King g1 Bishop to h3
a discovered check King h2 and now of
course Queen f3 will force checkmate as
this is a the threat of mate you cannot
defend it and after King captures of
course Quint h1 is made so that was also
in the position but being of course
decided not to do anything you have to
recapture Sunday - and he just resigned
the game so really exciting stuff
excellent win for Fabi and we're going
to discuss the standings after we show
all the games that I'm intending to show
from from today but this is the last
video I'll be uploading today I'm pretty
tired and well there is always tomorrow
for to finish off foreign April vs MVL
games yeah that's the game I do hope you
enjoyed it I would like to thank Mark
magner and Iligan Civic for your
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot - really appreciate it as usual you
can check to my previous videos here
thank you for watching and I will see
you soon continuing the coverage of the
Magnus Invitational and in
until it finishes so I think you're I
will season and have an excellent rest
of your day